You don't want to start this show actually by doing this, this is so funny, man.
Okay. There's there's a weird, I I've,
I've got to the point where no matter what I say about anything on Twitter,
somebody is offended. It doesn't matter. It really sincerely doesn't matter. Uh,
we live in a really sensitive time.
A lot of people are pretending that their feelings are hurt and a lot of
people's feelings are actually hurt. However, um, I just,
I don't think about. My Twitter isn't really for comedy.
It's just for me doing dumb. Like I don't give a about it. You know? So,
uh, I tweeted,
I was in the Albuquerque airport and the, uh, the,
my flight was delayed for about two hours and it said, and, and it was just,
I was looking around at just how weird Albuquerque was Albuquerque is so
Albuquerque,
like there's so many like the artwork is just so I don't even know what to call
it. It's like every other painting is of a stick figure like this,
you know? And like Tetris, like pyramids.
I don't know where they got that or what the it is. And you know, I,
I figured it's very Mexico inspired, but, um,
I just tweeted bro, Albuquerque, you know, I've been to some shitholes,
but Holy God, you make Jacksonville look like paradise,
whatever Jacksonville Albuquerque,
you got some great people. Actually,
I had a great time in Albuquerque doing my show, but once I left the show,
where am I? People live there for some reason.
And it's all good. Now here's the thing, dude,
if I'm in LA fine,
somebody says they hate Los Angeles. I go like this. Oh cool.
If I'm from New Jersey, I'm from Montclair, New Jersey. If somebody says, Hey,
um, I'm from Montclair, New Jersey sucks. I go like this,
that's it. I don't get my feelings hurt because I am not my place.
And if someone says, Hey, you suck. Sometimes I get my feelings hurt.
But most of the time I go like this, huh? Grow your skin.
All right. So I tweeted this and I even think about it.
Cause I was just in the air airport and I was just like, Jesus Christ,
this place. You know, imagine living here,
it made the news original medicine wellness center,
approach to treatment is both functioning. There's an ad. this ad.
Never go here. ads on.
It's always a woman with this voice as a medicine,
Claus ad get out of here. This is what it said on the, I made a set.
It was a segment dude. This is the funniest thing.
Good afternoon.
Albuquerque has been a punching bag for a few celebrities as they've made their
way through town.
The latest a well-known comedian who bashed the city after playing Getty city
owned treasure,
the chemo news thirteens Rebecca Atkins is live there with level. You call.
Your theater chemo,
which is how you help cancer.
So all of a sudden your place is making me think of
cancer. Okay. Were you playing chemo? Okay, cool. Cancer.
Let's do this show. Let's rock out guys. Hey.
Hey cancer. Ah, cool. Let's rock out. Here we go. You guys ready?
Where are you playing? The cancer dome. Oh, um,
Oh now here's how bad Albuquerque sucks. I'm playing the thing and it won't,
it won't play that. Even the website is like done.
They probably took it down because they heard I was around with it. God it.
What's going on here, dude. I want to play video.
We'll resume in 15 seconds. It says the
play. Why won't this play? Oh God dude. You know what?
This goes back to my. If you're going to invent something, make it work.
It's not playing. I did. I refreshed.
Why won't this work? This is how much Albuquerque sucks.
The website won't even play. All right, I'm going to draw. Oh, here we go.
All right. What is this dude?
Your company. You keep your garage door opener, functioning properly.
Call the genuine, the original, the overhead door company today.
The overhead door company. Cool. All right. Good afternoon.
Albuquerque has been a punching bag for a few celebrities as they've made their
way through town.
The latest a well-known comedian who bashed the city after city
owned treasure, the chemo,
the cancer does Rebecca Atkins is live there with what he said and how people
are responding. Rebecca. There's a lady live at the place.
Well came according to ticket sales.
This is where Christa Leah performed it last Thursday.
But while according to ticket sales.
What? Just Google it they're acting like they did so many,
so much research. Well, according to his ticket sales, what do you mean?
Cause 1500 people bought tickets to see me.
That's not according to ticket sales. Just the look.
Well,
according to ticket sales and geographical location of where the chemo theater
was and crystally his flight plan.
Dude, my computer is broken. Yes. Yes.
My computer's broken dude. And you know,
you didn't want thing for this dude and a God computer's
broken, man. It, you know what to do with the day. This sucks, man,
dude, I just want one guy taking away.
You know what dude I've been working so hard, man. I've been going,
I've been flying back and forth and cities. Sh I mean,
I was in Albuquerque dude. I was in Albuquerque. I was in Albuquerque.
Pure crashed my no. My computer crashed. I'm.
What is it? It just done. Dude here.
One fire dude flying solo, dude.
I'm a one thing to work, dude. I'm, I went to, I went to, I went to Albuquerque.
I went to Santa Fe, which is actually really beautiful. Who knew, dude?
It's so beautiful. It's like heaven. You go to Santa Fe. I swear to God.
And I went to, I went to, uh, you go to Albuquerque.
And when I was talking to people to Albuquerque, they're like, will you go next?
I was like Santa Fe. And they were like, Oh good luck. You know what dude,
do you know who you are? Santa Fe's beautiful, man. If I die,
if I died and woke up in Santa Fe and Jesus Christ was like,
you've got to live here for the rest of your life.
I'm like this smooth sailing dude. There's hot Springs. There's 10,000 ways.
There's a place called 10,000 waves where you can just go and chill and hear
water falling.
Good afternoon. Albuquerque has been a punching bag for a few celebrities.
They've made their way through town. The latest a well-known comedian.
I was on stage when I was on stage talking about Albuquerque. I said,
you know what? Albuquerque is like, it's like a place. Oh no.
I said this in Santa Fe the day after I said, you know what?
Albuquerque is like, it's like a plate.
It's like if the whole world blew up and then they were like, okay,
well I guess we've got to start from scratch.
And then nine years later that this is what they had. They're like, wait,
we it's kind of impressive. We did this at nine years,
but also it's not as good as it was.
That's why Albuquerque is like a post-apocalyptic nine year,
nine years after the post apocalypse, nine years after the apocalypse.
That's what Albuquerque is like. And they're like, yeah,
we only got the buildings this high,
but we have a theater that we call the chemo by mistake.
And it was right next to cancer Mart
here. We have the tumor Valley, uh, what do you call it?
The tumor Valley. My, I swear to God, dude.
I can't remember words and. What is the house that moves mobile home?
Um, dude, I'm so, so this is what, so then I said on, on Twitter,
I was making fun of Albuquerque because if you live in Albuquerque,
you got to know where the you live. Don't pretend the isn't Narnia.
The building's about this high. You got to crouch down to get into any place.
Ash, the city after playing Getty city owned treasure, the chemo.
These are teams, Rebecca.
[inaudible] what he said and how people are responding. Rebecca.
Always with the way too long as news newscasters do it.
When they jump on the last sentence. If you're in the field,
jump on that last sentence, jump on it. We're going live.
This is me. This is me. If I'm a newscaster, we're going live to Krista,
Leah in the field. And to see what some of the locals have to say about,
Hey guys, how's it going? I'm cutting them off. I'm feeling it out, dude,
rather than that's way better than we're going live to the field. Crystal, Leah,
to see how locals feel about what he said on Twitter.
Hi, how's it going? I just want to do this too long, man.
I could eat lunch in the middle of that. Pause. That pause is so long.
A baby came out of it.
So.
So still Leah performed at less Thursday. But while he was here,
he had some sort of a bad experience.
No, your, Oh your bad news.
I didn't say I had a bad experience. I just said Albuquerque
[inaudible].
After Chris D'Elia is a big name in the comedy world. Thirsty shine.
Just calling me an actor. You know what I mean? By letting me know,
you know what dude you say other people's lines, dude.
He performed at the chemo theater. I know. I look like a tired Eagle.
Um, I don't like how you laughed at dad. To be honest,
it was his second time in Albuquerque.
But something on this visit left a bad taste in his mouth.
Writes that, you know, it's amazing.
But something about this visit left a bad taste in his mouth.
By the way, they've shown the theater in this video, 14 times so far,
get more footage. So much of this from the top, dude,
this is such a news to get the top of the theater and then come down
at the chemo theater.
But something left a bad taste in this comedian's mouth.
He tweeted on Twitter that Albuquerque wasn't good.
We've talked to some of the locals to see what they have to say.
Always panning down. Dude. Just show it.
You don't have more footage just because you're moving the camera.
We can tell dude, guess what? Every time they do this too,
they come down and there's a parts.
Plus auto parts car drive by same footage.
Also parts plus auto parts. If parts is in your title twice,
change it parts. Plus auto parts. Come on down to parts.
Plus auto parts where well parts.
If your parts and parts that'll be parts. 50 plays
parts. Plus auto parts, dude,
too many PS
parts, auto parts plus parts of partum, depression, parts, pardon? Put plots,
the parts, parts, dude. Get it together. Albuquerque.
You have a auto place called parts plus auto parts and also
a theater named after cancer.
Dude. Even death Valley is like, we wouldn't have done that.
What? Even Regina Saskatchewan is like, wow,
they up with their titles and we rhyme with vagina,
dude. Regina, are you kidding me?
That's like naming your city parks, puck suckers.
Hey guys, where are you from? Puck suckers. Wait, what?
Like did you say suckers? No. I said pock suckers. That's a place.
Cause Regina is a place I got to start over the thing.
And now the ad's not working great because been because I waited too long
because the,
because Albuquerque is obviously in some sort of deficit that now I have to
watch another ad for the overhead door.
It's it's it's
it's it's. The overhead door is what this company is called. Dude.
Japanese steak. Just look at these places. Years of tradition in serving hot,
fresh and authentic. Look at these places in Albuquerque, exotic flavors,
fresh choices. Oh, fresh choices,
fresh choices.
Good afternoon. Albuquerque has been a punching bag for a few celebrities.
They've made their way through town.
The latest a well-known comedian who bashed the city after playing Getty city
owned treasure,
the chemo new thirteens Rebecca Atkins is live there with what he said and
bonded by Rebecca. Well, Kim, according to the ticket sales,
this is where Christa Leah performed at last Thursday. But while he was here,
he had some sort of a bad experience.
Okay.
And Thursday night he performed at the chemos theater.
I mean, I hate this joke. I don't like how you laughed at dads.
It was his second time in Albuquerque,
but something on this visit left a bad taste in his mouth about
his performance downtown. He took to Twitter to take a jab at Albuquerque sane.
I've been to some blank fools,
but surely God you make Jacksonville look like paradise.
The post has been retweeted almost 600 Jacksonville look like
paradise.
Imagine it for that's the way I wish he said, bro, Albuquerque,
you know, I wish you said that part. You make Jack. She didn't say that holes.
But good afternoon Albuquerque. Huh?
Dude.
Perky scene. I've been to some blank holes,
but Holy God you make Jacksonville look like paradise.
The post has been retweeted almost.
God. You know what, man? I wish I said something besides a paradise.
Just so they had to, before I put the tweet out, I was like,
what's better than parrot. What's a funnier thing than paradise. But I was like,
Oh, who gives a? Paradise is what everybody knows. I wish I,
I wish I was more creative now that they said it.
It would have been so much better. You know what I mean?
Albuquerque it, Oh, he took to Twitter and said,
I've been to some blank holes,
but Holy God you make Jacksonville look like the inside of a
sloshy.
You make Jacksonville look like it makes the sound slosh. When it walks.
Times. I just thought that was pretty rude of him.
It was kind of unnecessary to bash a place that you're
attending.
We spoke to weren't too happy about what he said.
Unnecessary too. I just thought that was pretty rude of him.
It was kind of unnecessary to bash a place that you're
attending.
The people we spoke to. Weren't too happy about what he said. It's pretty crazy.
They don't give a people. We talked to weren't so happy.
Oh.
I mean I've courteous. Not that bad.
You just got to go to like the good parts of it.
Albuquerque is not bad that bad. You just gotta go to the good parts of it.
You know what? The good parts of Albuquerque are Los Angeles.
But her people had mixed feelings.
This person listed off Albuquerque staples like green chili and the Sandias
and said,
what more could you want others agreed with Dalea with one person saying
they're from here and should be offended, but then said you're right.
Hashtag passed the meth.
Hashtag passed the meth. And I'm fine.
Shortly after that tweet,
he posted again saying Albuquerque and Jacksonville crowds are awesome though.
Actually.
But some people feel posts like that could scare Taurus away.
They're probably not going to want to come here now.
It's like, you should probably apologize for that.
We also reached down to Albuquerque is tourism department.
They say the post is unfortunate,
but they'd like to know if something set Dalea off while he was here.
They do say however they're appreciative of all the locals that stood up for the
city came back to you. Okay. Thanks for Becca.
Now we also reached to out to Dalea through his Twitter.
We have not yet heard back.
He did have some nice things to say about Santa Fe in Twitter,
after performing at the Lensic.
Just so many, just keep and. We wonder what he thinks about Seattle.
Just like, okay. You know, also said to cliff hanger,
how they left it.
Although we did have some nice things to say about Santa Fe, by the way,
she's saying that at the end in the background,
the next news is I swear to God the next segment, it says child shot.
How did I beat out that story?
One of Albuquerque zone slain,
but I tweeted. It was a blank hall.
Maybe Albuquerque.
That's the problem.
Start from there.
Rename your theater and then move on.
How on earth is that a thing?
When I saw it, I laughed wholeheartedly, dude.
I laughed so hard when I was like, Oh my God, dude,
people are literally sliding into my DMS with these emojis. you, bro.
Don't come back to New Mexico. Hey, guess what, man?
I didn't say anything about New Mexico. I love New Mexico.
Santa Fe Bichon Albuquerque
shocks. Also I will come back.
I love the crowds. The crowds in Albuquerque are awesome.
The people in Albuquerque are awesome.
Stop naming your theaters after cancer. That's all
also I don't even really give a. I'm sure it's a great place.
I was there for eight hours twice. I'm sure it's fine.
How could you get upset about somebody saying something like that?
I mean, I'm not talking about the people in the news.
Obviously they know even the newscasters are like, uh,
this is what we're reporting on it.
Like is this between this and one of the kids we got got shot. Well,
let's lead with the let's lead with the more depressing story
anyway.